we're here for the biggest fight of the
century saturday night i'm expecting to
come out walk through that tunnel sixty
thousand people swing uh singing sweet
caroline
uh usyk waiting in the ring
people singing his name people singing
my name
you know the intro michael buffer
announcing let's get ready to rumble
fans going crazy the first bell goes
it's such a beautiful sound it's uh in
the gym it's normally a buzzer if you
know boxing it's only like a little
buzzer that goes up in the gym but that
bell sound ding ding ding
round one is underway
um the lights are just shining on that
ring everything around you is like black
it's dark
the lights are shining on that ring and
it's like it's a phenomenal feeling
really phenomenal feeling do you think
people don't always give you credit for
your boxing ability given what you've
achieved
well
i i never look at it like that you know
well look there's 60 000 people coming
out so they must like something about
what i'm doing but i don't want to be
like
searching for
so much love i just hope people
appreciate boxing as a whole the whole
undercard me
it's going to be a good night boxing
underrated overrated valued
at least certain people value i think
let's not focus on the negative about
the people that don't value what i do i
like to focus on people that do value
what i do
how do you deal with fight night itself
you know obviously there's pressure but
you always look relaxed but when you
wake up in the morning do you have
butterflies are you excited
or is it just something to get through
and execute well when talk us through
the day so you start with visualization
from training camp putting yourself in
that scenario mentally so when you kind
of wake up look no matter how you feel
no matter how you feel tired achy um
i i go in i know spyro isn't the
opponent but there's times when gotta go
in i've got four or five guys waiting to
spar me and i may not feel 100 but the
ultimate thing is i get out the other
end i always perform i go there and on
fight night your adrenaline whether
you've got a headache you've got a bad
foot a bad hand whatever it may be
the environment just overtakes you and
makes you feel at ease like you just
feel like there's nothing else that
matters in the world right now except
for this event that's going on but do
you think when you wake up in the
morning do you feel a little bit nervous
or were you totally calm all the time oh
well before before i used to get nervous
it was our fight days here you know when
you're driving to the arena
you know like when i was
at 02 yesterday
it hit home it's like wow i remember
when i used to fight here like this is
this is serious i used to pull up here
nervous but
do you know what's amazing about life is
um
tomorrow always comes
no matter what happens today
tomorrow will always come and
this isn't forever it just happens to be
a part of my life now
and uh it will all be done one day so i
try not to get too
bent up over it because we're all going
through this process where today comes
tomorrow comes and we just keep on going
saturday will be saturday will come and
sunday will be here
in the blink of an eye
whatever happens and you're an
inspirational figure for so many people
and we've all gone through a really
strange time in the last 18 months
what has inspired you or who's inspired
you in this time
to push on who's been your inspiration
can you think of anything
who's inspired me to push on
the olympics was it watching some other
sporting person your
your little boy no one
no one everything all of it all of it
just life in general you know look we're
all here
for a certain amount of time
we're blessed
you know we could have been born
in a
i was watching something where i was
like if you was born in like the 40s you
just finished world war one then the
spanish flew here and this war and that
so they we're just blessed to be here
water
lights
simple things i can't complain so uh not
much
i don't actually need much to keep me
motivated when i look around
like what am i gonna complain about my
my delivery came an hour late
oh you know what i mean like i can't
complain
in this environment that we're blessed
with there's not much to complain about
and to have the fans back finally what
does that mean for me it's it just it
makes me humble because in a way that i
just got to dedicate myself to the craft
so i can go out there and perform for uh
all these fans that come out i don't
take it for granted it's not like i've
ticked that box
like forget it now i'm happy i've done
what i've had to do um i fought in front
of x amount of people i actually look at
it and i'm like why i need to make sure
i practice and i work hard because
i want to give these guys value you know
what i mean so that's how i pay them
back honestly i really try i really try
hard
i've got certain strengths i've got
certain weaknesses but i definitely push
so i can get better so i can pay these
guys back and come out
there's your motivation the fans the
fact yeah yeah yeah they've been a big
mo yeah because i've worked all the way
through the pandemic and
i fought december 12th and i know
on christmas day new year's day i was in
the gym training so
that's probably the way i do pay them
back that's my motivation yeah hey jake
good luck have a great fight thank you
so much and i'll see you soon thank you